some of events that I mentioned this
Lake plot have already been confirmed by
either previous promoter trailers while
some are yet to be seen if true or false
if you watch the video mining which I
introduced with the lake script pages of
the season finale in which I also showed
you the leaked script for season
premiere that turned out to be a hundred
percent accurate I think it's safe to
say that those certain leaks are the
pure truth however if you don't want
anything spoiled it's time for you to
close this video before I start let me
give a quick shout out to freaky dr.
Spanish Game of Thrones related channel
who shared its leak in the first place
the link of his channel as well as the
link of translated posted basically
translated whole freaky doctor's review
will be in the description down below
the episode starts off with the
aftermath of the battle the feel of
Firebird Lannisters entirely store
pretty much easily defeated Bronn utter
saving Jamie's life I'm assuming twice
from Dragon and most probably from
drowning as well as Jamie what's wrong
with him and why on earth would he do
something as crazy as charging towards
dragon Jamie starts to wonder how he's
going to tell Cersei that their forces
to commence applause and how dispose the
world loaded from Highgarden are now
lost and now have no way to pay their
own Bank the scene then cuts to Denny's
army also facing the aftermath of the
battle handling prisoners and so on but
also the punishment Randall adding
entirely who betrayed her own house and
pledged their forces to search his cause
the nearest all-star list to bend the
knee and serve her but Reynolds says
that he'll Redis or an oath to Cersei
and says that she's his queen the Khan
also follows in his father's example and
denies to bend the knee as well which
leads Dany toward the dragon to rouse
them which horrifies Tyrion who says
it's unnecessary and brutal this outcome
matches with bears being concerned about
the nearest in the recently published
preview in that shot versus being
concerned about his screen and says to
Tyrion that he needs to find a way to
make her listen Sina Dragonstone is next
the nearest returns with drug on the
dragon stone and when she arrives just
know is they're waiting for her Drago me
the nearest on his back lands in front
of John who is a little taken back at
first but then dragon gets closer Jon
Petz him a bit and jorgen allows it as
expected this leaves Dany shock and
continues her intrigue for Jon after
getting down from jørgen the nearest
talks about her dragons with Jon and
states that they are not beasts to her
but rather her children
at this point Jorah Mormont arrives at
Dragonstone and finally reunites with
Daenerys Daenerys is very happy that Joe
is back and healthy but Jorah skeptical
about Jon Snow but it's not clear if he
knows who John is from the start there's
a point where John figures out who Jorah
is son of jor-el Doug warming up to each
other something like Jorah and Sam
earlier this season
John offers lung Club back to Jorah
since it's his house his ancestral
weapon by George fuses saying his father
gave it to John for a reason Winterfell
is next for a flock of Ravens is being
sent out those Ravens so which one is
being worked by Brian go beyond the wall
to see what the night king is up to by
the night King Sansa set and bran is
either forced out of the mind of a raven
or leaves out of fear back to
dragonstone junkets reinstating the
Torian bran have arrived back at
Winterfell which obviously makes John
happy but doesn't have the time to think
about it the raven will also include
information regarding the night king and
his army who brands so marching towards
eastwatch-by-the-sea tyrion and varys
are wondering if the nurse will be as
brutal as her father and how Denny did
things that were unnecessary such as
burning tarly's and what they should do
about it then they decide to inform
Cersei about the night King and his
undead army in order to persuade Circe
into joining them which would pause or
end the war since every man in Westeros
will be needed to fight in the great war
that is coming knowing sirs his opinion
regarding Tyrion and considering how big
or should I say small chances of
persuading her to send her forces north
while she would stay on the Iron Throne
they decided to get in contact with
Bronn to trick Jaime to meet with them
since Jamie might not be willing to talk
to Tyrion since he killed their father
less time Jamie mentioned Tyrion was in
conversation with bran and he stated
that if he sees his brother ever again
he'll split him in two
Tyrion uses ser Davos as smuggling
talents to sneak past King's Landing
defenses to meet with Jaime and Bronn
Brownlee's Jaime Tesoro car comes where
Tyrion is air even though he said he
would Jaime will not harm Tyrion since
Jamie now knows for certain that Tyrion
did not kill Joffrey as well as that
their father just wanted Terry Undead
Tyrion tries to convince Jaime to tell
Cersei to surrender and join them to
fight against the undead army while they
stalks her douses walk into King's
Landing through the armourers and
blacksmiths when he runs into a ginjury
working as a blacksmith making swords
and such that was jokes that he left him
robbing and ginjury sees him ginjuries
glad he encountered once again a man who
saved his life but also means that he
started being a blacksmith especially
since he is making everything for the
Lannisters for those who killed his
father let me just say that Ginja being
at King's Landing is not surprising at
all considering the Davos told him to
keep robbing until he reaches King's
Landing injury firstly responded with
gold cloaks are looking for me pawning
that he wouldn't be safe over there but
that was convinced him that he's going
to be completely safe since the gold
cloaks don't know how he looks like
anyway that was invites him to come with
him to which ginjury agrees and takes
out a weapon he forged for himself a
Warhammer with a stag card entered
Tyrion died was an injury mid-back for
the robot was to go back to Dragonstone
battle gold cloak stop them to ask a few
questions now Estelle's than there are
traders three two gold cloaks as then
what they trade - that was censored them
they trade aphrodisiac crabs and offers
these crabs to them as a form of bribery
to let them go
while that was his working on a solution
ginjuries getting a little nervous as he
has his work hammer hidden in a rowboat
trying not to raise suspicion but then
the most famous dwarf in the world
shoves up and walks past the gold cloaks
which of course makes the gold cloaks to
automatically see through Davos as
deception this is when ginjury takes his
Warhammer and kills both gold cloaks
hearing one in the head and the other in
the chest the three make it back to
Dragonstone where Jon and injury meet
for the first time both being bastards
and both meeting each other's father's
makes them relate and become friends
tyrion arriving back at Dragonstone
danger already being a dragon stone is
when a reunion between those two is
taking place
tyrion says the Lannisters will not join
because they don't believe in the night
King and think it's a trap which is the
moment John decides that he must bring a
proof about the night kings and the
undead's Army's existence so the south
sole the Lord's could witness the real
danger
Jan is convinced that the only way to
unite all the kingdoms in order to stand
a chance against the night king is to
capture and bring a white to the south a
bit later John DuBose during injury are
preparing to set sail for the
eastwatch-by-the-sea end just before
they leave John tells the nearest
somewhere along the
well if I don't return you won't have to
deal with the king in the north anymore
- which Daenerys responds with I've
gotten used to him the following scene
is that eastwatch-by-the-sea where those
traveling from Dragonstone meets tormund
where he and other wildlings have been
sent in the season premiere to mend of
all torment then takes John to the ice
cells where he has put the Brotherhood
without banners along with the Hound
Brotherhood tells John that the Lord of
Light wants them beyond the wall which
is when John offers them a chance to go
with him the Brotherhood without banners
being a deist which is not surprising at
all since it's where they have been
heading to since the first episode of
the season and the Hound saw a vision in
the flames
ginjury doesn't trust them since they
sold him to Melisandre back in the third
season Jorah is supposedly recognised by
tormund who knows his father was Lord
Commander of the Nights Watch and who
made their life hell for a long time
fighting the free folk John on the other
hand doesn't trust the Hound since he
knows what he has done for Joffrey and
some stuff Sansa has told him he had
done but either way they decided to go
together under John's leadership and
start to range beyond the wall to try to
capture white in Winterfell Littlefinger
is starting his game by stirring things
up at Lords of the North saying that
their King has abandoned them and sends
on the other hand is trying to keep the
situation under control
aurilla sees that sense I might want the
note for herself and she also sees sense
and not backing John the way she should
Arya of course doesn't just Littlefinger
mostly because back in the second season
while being Tyminski bearer are a
witness Littlefinger plotting against
her family
Arya starts to spy on him which
Littlefinger being the cunning us he is
recognizes Littlefinger also says that
she doesn't have an agenda which he
admits his dangerous since it's hard to
manipulate someone like that but he can
try to deceive her Baelish pulls the
letter send some a to sign back in the
very first season asking Robb to
bandonion stating that Ned was a traitor
Baelish pulls her out and make sure
arias is in hiding it which Arya later
decides to look for Littlefinger knows
that if Arya was to find this letter
she'll be even more suspicious that
sense amounts to overture of John manera
finds that Petyr Baelish is watching her
and he believes everything is going
according to a plan
all town is the last and I see Sam grow
tired of the way the masters are
handling his stories about the night
King and his undead army and blinded by
their knowledge
he knows he must leave to Winterfell
Gilly continues to learn how to read she
has been reading a diary or record of
events by the now dead high septon mine
art she's reading them too uninterested
or just busy Sam Giller reads a piece
that says Maynard issued an annulment
for a prince whose name Mishima is
pronounced since she's still learning to
read and says something like Rhaegar
which is most probably Prince Rhaegar
Targaryen there stated that Maynard the
remarry that Prince very rich Rhaegar or
not to someone else in a secret ceremony
in Dorne as probably all of you know
Lyanna Stark and Prince Rhaegar were in
the Tower of joy in the red mountains of
Dorne if this comes sure that would mean
that John is not a bastard that was born
out of wedlock but rather a trueborn son
of Lea and Rhaegar Targaryen as his
parents were supposedly married then sin
decides to leave the cetera knowing that
no one there will help him with things
happening in the north since there is
only one person that believes what he
says and even then it's dismissed
Sam Gillian baby same board a cart and
leave old town with hearts Benin books
he might have taken and head to
Winterfell there you have it guys
detail review for the fifth episode of
the season as you can see most of those
events have already been confirmed by
either promos trailers previous or
leaked photos and it's certainly safe to
say that those leaks are quite accurate